one question i want you to think about
real quick is
how often do you look at the cover art
of your games i mean like truly looking
at them not just glancing at them for
this question i'm not talking about
multiplayer games say
apex or call of duty that change their
logos whenever there's new content to
keep it looking fresh
i mean like single player games cover
art is used to entice and inform the
player what the game is
some games do this in secretive ways
like heavy rain which has a piece of
origami on the cover which doesn't tell
the player much at first
but other games mainly first person
shooters have the main protagonist on
the front cover
the reason i bring this up is that far
cry does things differently the main
character is nowhere to be seen on these
covers
now this isn't some monumental discovery
anyone who's played a far cry game knows
ubisoft loves to market the villains of
their game more than anything even in
the most recent entry far cry 6 with the
trailer
only showing the villain whereas the
protagonist is not shown at
all now this isn't for every far cry
game but at least for the games we're
going to be discussing today that being
far cry 3
4 and 5 this fits something else to look
at is the de-evolution of our
protagonists far cry 3 and 4 have name
protagonists with an interesting
backstory and reasons for being in the
situations they're in but with far cry 5
not only do we not have a name
only going by rook or deputy we don't
speak and there isn't even a set look to
our protagonist as this game offers
major customization in the form of
outfits and the ability to change our
gender something not present in the past
games
it's not wrong to assume it may be the
same with far cry 6 since going off the
description of the game it looks like
we're going to be playing a person named
danny rojas a local resident of the
island the game takes place in fighting
against anton castillo are presumed to
be
main villain we aren't someone special
we're just one of the thousands of
people on the island that decided to
take a larger steps towards their goal
at least that's what it looks like case
in point ubisoft seems to have put more
time on their villains and less time on
the protagonists which isn't a bad thing
at all and i think due to this decision
they made the villains more likeable and
more compelling than they actually
should have been
most games tell a story about the
protagonist where we are playing as them
in their story but with some far cry
games mainly far cry 5 it always felt
like we were just the person present in
the villain story
not them present in ours but that
previous point is what i want to discuss
today why are these villains so
fantastic so likable that you want more
screen time with them even if it's just
for a few short moments you just want to
see and engage with them more as they're
just that entertaining
let's talk about
[Music]
[Music]
so not only does ubisoft have a common
trend of keeping the main villain on the
cover they also
keep the trend of introducing them in a
sinister way with the intro we'll cover
each of the villains individually in a
bit but i want to talk about their
introductions to their respective games
as a whole first
starting this off though with far cry 3
we play as a man named jason brody your
typical white american kid from l.a
no care in the world with his only focus
being on what he's going to drink next
we get a nice montage of him and his
friends partying on the island
with certain freeze frames to introduce
the characters the beginning text before
all of this however is a quote from
alice in wonderland there will be many
quotes like this throughout the game
which i always felt was a reference to
jason beginning his new life
being a part of the island tribe and
doing things the islanders do is
something jason has never experienced
and as we know from playing the game
he's a totally different person by the
end of it the person that would ignite
this new life in jason
is vos foss is the first antagonist of
the game and is a clear psychopath vos
is also the leader of the pirates a
local group that kidnaps and ransoms
people for easy money
the main reason vos is so likable is
because he's funny
from the early moments of the game he
always does something evil then follows
it up with something witty i ruled his
[ __ ] kingdom
shut the [ __ ] up or you die
what is it jason jason what is it
why aren't you laughing now like you did
up there but is this not fun anymore
have i failed to entertain you
it's clear he loves to toy with his
victims especially jason
voss knows that he's in control of us at
all times and he can toy with us as much
as he likes
even though there's no actual camera
being pointed at him it always felt that
he owns the spotlight whenever he's on
screen making sure he's the one everyone
looks at no matter where he is
i just hope that you two pieces of fox
are more entertaining than your friends
tata bye bye
get you every [ __ ] time man another
good example of this is during our
escape every time i played instead of
continuing on ahead and progressing the
narrative i always stop and watch vosh
with these prisoners
just for the ending comment
oh my god did you did you realize i just
shot them all in sequence
one after the other i did not do it on
purpose if you answer the small
questions in life
can you clean this [ __ ] [ __ ] up even
though he's off the beaten path in the
background he still owns that spotlight
we mentioned
after attempting to escape we see vos
toy with us even more as
he catches us once again but still gives
us the chance to run away and escape
knowing that we probably won't make it
far anyway far cry 4 at least to me is
considered the odd one out of the three
far cry 4's protagonist is ajay galle
the reason it's the odd one out is that
our protagonist has actual relations to
the antagonist aj galle's main objective
was to spread his mother's ashes next to
lakshmana
it's not as simple as it seems though as
the country is currently in the midst of
a civil war
we're being transported via bus until
it's stopped by the country's dictorial
force the royal army an
argument ensues in the bushes shot up
thankfully we were not shot but we are
taken out of the bus at gunpoint
pagan min the leader of the group
arrives and isn't quite happy with the
situation
stop the bus
yes stop the bus
not shoot the bus
i'm very particular with my words
stop shoot
stop shoot
pagan is quite like voss a little
psychotic but also a little comedic
killing his guard over one mistake but
then getting mad he got his expensive
shoes bloody
what separates him from boss however is
he's quite soft-spoken
it's good that he doesn't consider aj an
enemy and is quite compassionate as well
as he apologizes for the current
situation then takes a photo to
commemorate the moment
aj however is less than happy as would
anyone who just saw someone get stabbed
death with a pen
afterward pagan man invites us to his
palace where we see him offer some
delicious crab rangoon
at the table is pagan his associate paul
and darpan it's found out that pagan
knew who eshwari was but at this time we
don't exactly know the false story yet
pagan is not an evil person so to speak
he is and there's definitely many
examples to prove this but as long as
you're nice to him he will help you and
meet your expectations
when he leaves he says sit down and
enjoy the food and he'll be right back
if you take him at his literal word
after about 15 minutes or so he'll come
back and actually take you to lakshmana
like you wanted which as we discover is
not a place but a person
aj's father mohan was the leader of the
golden path his mother ashwari wanted to
fight alongside him but mohan deemed her
unsuitable to do so mohan instead sent
her to be a spy but instead of spying on
pagan she fell in love with him the two
then had a girl named lakshmana who at
the age of 1 was killed by mohan
ishwari would kill mohan ford and leave
kirat to live in the united states
this would make pagan our stepdad this
also explains why his compassionate side
comes out when we talk with him we're
related to him and he treats his family
well whether they're biological or not
of course to progress we can't do this
ending so we escaped the palace and
helped the golden path for far cry 5 we
start very similarly to far cry 3
watching a slideshow of videos except
this is inside footage on the cult of
eden's gate
someone tried to capture footage of the
cult but was found out and killed in
front of the church
we pan out and see fellow officers with
us in a helicopter we could tell from
the early moments of the game that
joseph seed is going to be very
different from the other villains in
this series
the sheriff constantly brings up to the
marshall that there's no shame in
backing out of this operation
even saying that joseph terrifies him as
we walk the compound we see all the
cultist members surrounding us and they
clearly aren't happy we're here even in
the church when we meet joseph the cult
members block our path
protecting him from us we can see the
immense power that he has simply by
speaking he can calm the entire
situation down he also speaks very
softly just like pagan
so much so that when he does get angry
at certain points later in the game it's
a lot scarier than it should be normally
after the cult leaves joseph with his
family behind him presents his hands
offering himself up to be arrested
saying not to worry and that god won't
let us take him
where after we do arrest him we hear him
say the words sometimes the best thing
to do is walk away
in reference to the future events of the
game another reference to the future
events of the game is right before we
cuff him and i
saw
and behold it was a white horse
the white horse wall in the context of
his sentence actually means a white
horse he was using the sentence to also
refer to
sheriff white horse as well especially
putting emphasis on that last sentence
hell followed with him while directly
looking at us meaning we are joseph's
hell and he has to stop us
this game like far cry 4 also has a
secret ending where after five minutes
or so we leave and don't arrest joseph
the marshal is very confused and against
this but the sheriff knows we shouldn't
do this
now four people against dozens arresting
the leader of a cult in his own compound
can't really go right at all and it
definitely doesn't as we see the outcome
of our actions
the cult is so committed to saving
joseph that they will climb a moving
helicopter and one even jumped into the
blades causing it to crash
we then see one of the more intimidating
scenes of the game where we see joseph
speak to dispatch only to find out that
she was working with him the whole time
when we awake joseph talks to his
followers and calls for the reaping and
attempts to grab
everyone from the helicopter but we
managed to escape and start our long
journey attempting to stop the family
the intros of far cry are made purposely
to convey the sort of power and
motivation each antagonist has
boss is driven by money and power he
wants to make his captives feel
powerless while
also making money off them too pagan has
a vast amount of wealth enough to supply
his own army but has been at war with
the golden path for quite some time so
he's trying to eradicate them
and joseph and by extension the rest of
the seed family are a persuasive group
able to get their people to do their
bidding simply by asking
ubisoft structured these intros this way
for a reason within the first 10 to 20
minutes of the intro we get an
introduction of our protagonist and our
antagonist as well as the motivations
for their immoral acts and goals and why
we the hero
are tied to that motivation or goal of
theirs jason aj and the deputy have to
battle through tons of enemies to
complete their goals they are one
against a thousand this makes the
protagonist feel powerless which i'll
get to why this is super important at
the end of the video
but these villains wouldn't be as good
without us by definition an antagonist
cannot exist without a protagonist the
reason this person in the story is
considered the villain or antagonist is
that they either have goals that
conflict with the hero's goal like in
far cry 3 or both have the same goal but
one needs to beat the other to it like
in far cry 5.
jason wants to escape the island with
his friends foss won't let him do that
simple as that is there's a conflict and
both the deputy and joseph want to save
the people of the county
both their ways of saving people are
drastically different from one another
and both can have their way
one has to win one has to lose yes the
antagonist is the bad guys of the story
but it's the protagonists that continue
to push them throughout the story making
them appear more on screen and doing
more sinister acts
to reinforce this i think it's about
time we finally delve into the games
individually
starting with far cry 3.
[Music]
as stated before jason is new to
everything this island has to offer when
jason kills his first pirate his hands
tremble he hasn't done something like
this before i always thought it was a
weird gameplay gimmick at first but now
i've come to actually appreciate the
metaphor of the tatau
showing not just our skills evolving but
our mentality
at the beginning of the game we weren't
accustomed to climbing towers and
raiding outposts most times we would be
detected but as we grew our tatau evolve
showing that we too have evolved and now
sneaking through an outpost undetected
is a breeze
this evolution also happened in jason
himself becoming more familiar with
hunting animals and using unique types
of weaponry
in the game we can uncover that jason
was skilled in firearms somewhat thanks
to his brother grant who served in the
army but jason never actually killed
someone
shooting guns and taking someone's life
are two completely different things
jason was becoming more and more like a
killer he was
turning into vos when we encounter vos
at the end of the game and start the
weird dream sequence he says very
clearly
i am you and you are me even as we walk
the path citra asks us what kind of man
are we getting jason to question what he
wants to be and what his true purpose is
throughout the game jason rescues his
friends and every time he returns he
sounds more and more desperate to stay
even at one point outright saying he
doesn't want to leave you could pass
this off as maybe he really likes
hanging out with the rocky odd people
but what have we been doing for
95 percent of the game it's definitely
not been playing cards it's killing
pirates
jason's bloodlust has grown he loves
killing
he even says quote you know i never
thought i'd be able to kill somebody
the first time it felt wrong but now it
feels like a winning
throughout the flashback dream scenes we
see vos then jason appear but then vos
then jason again it's the game trying to
tell us that jason is turning into the
new voss this crazed killer
jason's friends are even starting to
notice this as when we rescue oliver
lisa pulls jason over and says that this
is affecting him too much
she's worried that the guns and tattoos
we have are affecting our minds
later in the game after killing boss and
completing citrus trial becoming the new
true rocky hot warrior jason meets with
the group one more time and says he's
not coming the whole time he wanted to
leave the island with his friends but
now he wants to stay
it's because he's finally figured out
what he wants to do in his life
vos is also driving jason insane at the
exact same time especially with his
infamous insanity line where we're doing
the same thing over and over again
expecting something to change
what he's saying isn't too far from the
truth jsync gets captured by vos
he escapes he attempts to rescue his
friends but then he's captured again
it happens three times throughout the
game and jason thinks something will
change
now obviously we do end up killing vosso
in a way we do change the outcome but
regardless it's something
interesting to think about each time the
same thing happens
he's captured then he escapes it's
actual insanity
my favorite scene of vos has got to be
before this however when we rescue lisa
foss gets quite down to earth with us
talking about his sister citra and
i'll just play a small clip at the end
real quick there was a time where i do
anything for my sister you know the
first time i ever killed was from my
sister
it was not enough for her no no no
please you see the thing about our loved
ones right
our [ __ ] loved ones they commonly fly
inside you every [ __ ] time so they
say to me
they save us but who the [ __ ] is it like
to be
them or me me i can
like you know like they [ __ ] think
that i need to make a [ __ ] choice
vos for the first time is talking about
his emotions the real reason for his
hatred of citra that's what opened my
eyes to vos he's chaotic and insane but
he's being real at the same time taking
into account the ending of the game and
everything with citra it really makes
you think about avas and if he's
actually the insane one
citra at a young age forced vos to kill
people for her she was demanding men and
she's still a demanding person now
at the end of the game if we decide to
kill lisa and jo and citro we have sex
with her as a final reward and she kills
jason in a ritualistic fashion she wants
jason to impregnate her so that she can
bear the perfect child who will be the
face of the rocky yacht
citra throughout the game even way
before the ending constantly enabled
jason's bloodlust saying that he would
make a fine warrior and that it's okay
to be this way
after taking a look at everything that
citra and vos have done it starts to
make you question both of them
is vos really not as insane as we
thought or maybe they're both deranged
and need to be left alone
it's extremely thought provoking and why
i love this scene so much
voss and far cry 3 to an extent is my
favorite entry in the series it makes
you think about all the craziness that
occurred on our journey and how much one
small thing can change a person
going from a kid to a killer and it's
voss that amplifies this in jason and
he's the reason jason's in this mess
he captured him and killed his brother
so it only makes sense to blame boss for
the downfall of jason's insanity there
is a bright side to this however as if
we do choose to help our friends jason
does acknowledge the darkness inside of
him but he knows he's better than that
and won't succumb to it which is quite a
good ending
[Music]
just like with the previous entry to
explain pagan we have to talk about
ajay ajay is not as naive as jason is
but he's definitely quite naive when it
comes to the golden path and he's also
quite dismissive of them at times as
well
aj even says that he's thankful for the
golden path but all he wants to do is
scatter his mom's ashes
it's not that he doesn't care for them
at all but it's definitely not a large
priority of his his mom purposely
withheld this information from him so
that he doesn't have to learn the
sinister
things his father did like killing his
stepsister lakshmana
as for pagan he was quite powerful and
wealthy early on in his life he owned a
small cartel in china but as he grew
more powerful he realized his death was
inevitably going to happen so he escaped
kira to live out his days pagan arrived
during the civil war and once it was
about to end he killed the heir to the
throne and became the new leader of
kirat
pagan sadly doesn't show up much in the
game as much as vos does but i believe
this is because the game is using pagan
to showcase really what's happening with
amita and sabal in all of our choices
from the moment we are saved we're
thrown into the golden path whether we
like it or not
amita says it's possible that we were
sent back to kirat for something even
greater and that if we help the golden
path we can spread ishwari's ashes we
have no choice but to kill the royal
army
pagan even brings this up at the end of
the game to whom am i speaking
the son who returned scattered his
mother's ashes or
the lunatic who has murdered his way to
the top of my mountain
it makes us question ourselves and who
we even are anymore you're then given
two options
kill or spare pagan killing him would
prove his point
that we're just someone who murdered a
bunch of people to get to the top of his
mountain but by showing restraint we've
proved that we are the same aj who came
to this country with his original goal
in mind
pagan is very honest with the people he
speaks to give him respect and he'll
provide it back
if we kill him we wouldn't have learned
what he tells us at the end of the game
by sitting down and eating he explains
it if we just sat at the table in the
beginning that none of this would have
happened he would have helped spread
aishwary's ashes and he would have been
given karat which is a shocking
revelation
kira was always going to be aj's pagan
purposely stopped the boss in the
beginning of the intro so he could pass
down leadership of the country tent
as we walk out pagan says that once we
spread those ashes pre-kirat aj
is gone and stays with the urn so that
begs the question
what happens next i simply continued
where she left off i killed so
many people for them but then i realized
i was only using lakshmana's death as an
excuse to do whatever i wanted to do
just as you use those ashes as an excuse
to do whatever you want to do
this and i mean this in no exaggeration
has got to be one of the best lines in
the game arguably the entire series
pagan used the death of his daughter to
kill thousands of people just like we
used our goal of spreading our mom's
ashes to justify joining the golden path
and killing thousands and it's
completely true we never
questioned anything we did all the
soldiers we killed the decisions we made
we did all of these as we thought it was
necessary to complete our goal
when it never needed to happen the
secret ending shows this simply by
waiting
pagan would have let us british wary's
ashes and then we could either have been
the king of kirat
or go home done and over within 20
minutes it was shocking to hear that he
wasn't just saying that to ajay he was
talking to us too the player we are aj
not only because we control him but our
motivations and our actions
every decision we made was so that we
could help spread ishwari's ashes we
used it as an excuse
we climbed those towers to show more of
the map this revealed more outposts
destroying those outposts gave us free
guns and money
things we could use to defeat the royal
army we did these things to become
stronger so that we could defeat pagan
and get to the location ishwari wanted
us to go
when this never needed to happen in the
first place pagan in one sentence
changed my whole thinking about this
game truly one of the best antagonists
this series has
he had me rethinking all the stuff we
did for kurat at the ending of the game
before meeting pagan you decide who
leads the golden path both
amida and sobal are terrible leaders
with outlandish ideas for the future of
this country
just like mohan sabal wants to stick to
the old ways of the golden path kirat
and the religious ideals of the country
but amida wants to break away from
tradition and start a new outlook for
the country but the way they go about
doing these is awful amida would turn
kirat into a drug state and seval would
use religion as a reason to justify his
acts whether they're good or bad
and we have to choose who we side with
because of our original actions of
leaving the palace we got swept up in a
tidal wave of terrible decisions that we
had no choice but to make
but at the end of all this we got to
spread her ashes so we had to make those
decisions right
i'm not so sure anymore
[Music]
far cry 5 is a little different our
character the deputy doesn't speak so we
really don't get to understand him as
much as a character but we can still
uncover lots about joseph and the seed
family far cry 5 decided to take a leap
and introduce 4 villains instead of 1
all of whom have their reasons for
existing in the game's world
joseph john and jacob are brothers with
faith being the adopted sister as from
some dialogue in the game you can find
out that her real name
is rachel jessup joseph from birth was
living a rough life he was a squatter
near some abandoned plant and ended up
bell hopping at a nearby hotel to make
ends meet he became entranced by
religion and hoped to hear more of the
voice as he calls it which we can assume
is god
joseph would eventually hear the voice
for a final time in a dream of his
showing a vision of darkness and
punishment which he called the collapse
he recruited his two brothers jacob and
john to help with his vision he was told
to make sure his followers were kept
safe from the imminent doom of the world
joseph is quite sadistic in these
actions
at one point in the game he tells us how
his wife and daughter were in a car
accident his wife died but his daughter
was still alive this was around the time
when god would tell him about the end of
the world so when an effort to prove his
worthiness he pinched the tube connected
to his daughter's face
killing her with voss he was crazy but
comedic pagan was also the same but he
made us question our journey
joseph at least to me kind of resembles
a bit of both of them
that crazy psychotic side where voss
killed people because he wanted to
joseph did it in the name of god and
with pagan making us question our
beliefs and if our journey was truly
worth it while also not wanting to kill
aj
joseph doesn't want to kill the deputy
even though at the end of the game when
we confront
him he says that he should have but he
restrains from doing so it's only until
we attack first that he attempts to take
our life
at the end of the game we're then given
two options resist or walk away
if you choose the resist option at the
end of the fight he will say a verse
from luke 23
34. forgive them father they do not know
what they do
he's telling god to forgive us as we
don't understand the repercussions of
our actions that being the collapse
if we leave then he says the verse from
luke 6 37
saying judge not lest you be judged
condemn not lest you be condemned
forgive and you will be forgiven
joseph is forgiving our actions because
we walked away this choice was our last
forgiveness
if we had chosen resist he has no choice
but to retaliate but since we didn't
he is forgiving us joseph isn't letting
this power get to his head however not
only is he quite calm in his decision
making but also understands he has sins
too
just like everyone else in the world
this is shown in his scarring of the
words greed
gluttony lust pride and sloth on his
body joseph also isn't the only member
of the family as stated previously
there's three other people involved in
this family jacob is the cult recruiter
john is the lawyer and secondary
spokesperson while faith serves as a
voice of the cult as well as controlling
them
although in some way they do end up
brainwashing the cult together
faith uses her bliss flowers jacob uses
mind control with the help of his music
box and john frequently baptizes people
in bliss-covered waters
for jacob he always projects to the
people that the lives of the few
outweigh the lives of the many which is
quite opposite from the traditional
quote saying that the lives of the cult
and the family are more important than
the rest of the non-believers
jacob also says that he calls the herd
when he switches up the wording
sometimes he also says call the weak
jacob gets rid of the weak by doing his
brainwashing test so that the cult can
have perfect soldiers
jacob during our capture explains that
during the war he was stranded in the
desert with no water or food
as a last resort he killed the native
squad mate miller so that he could
survive
a later medical report that he received
later deduced that he was suffering from
ptsd
he later became homeless and out of
money due to this and was then recruited
by
joseph john has always been about saying
yes it's everywhere in his bunker and
you can hear him say it tons of times
when he was younger he was beaten by his
parents until all he could say
was yes he used this as his motto for
the rest of his life
so jon has some serious childhood trauma
that joseph exploited making it easier
for john to follow him joseph even said
in game that
jon as a child was kind and loving which
made him an easy target for abuse and
exploitation the reason john carries
this specific motto of yes with him is
because when you just accept things into
your life and not question it your mind
is much more at peace
no more stress and anxiety about life
and its outcomes just
pure bliss speaking of bliss we have
faith our last member of the family and
the adopted one
tracy latter in the game says that she
knew faith before all this happened
faith or who was originally known as
rachel was a girl who suffered from lots
of abuse and turned to drugs for comfort
and joseph was able to comfort and help
her with this and she was actually able
to recover from her addiction
except during her boss fight she says
something quite different
you think i wanted this he plied me with
drugs he threatened me
i was 17 i was just a child
he kept her addiction going and she was
a child
it's quite heartbreaking to say the
least if you're noticing a trend
then you're correct joseph preyed upon
impressionable people
including his own family also that he
could further his cause
he's very manipulative and it almost
makes you feel bad for his family
with all this info being shown it's
clear that joseph is the most cruel out
of the three we've discussed
he may not be as well liked as the
previous villains but he is definitely a
very well written one at that
from his crazy motivations and actions
to that energy and power that he emits
that continues to linger in his
followers
submitting to him in doing what he wants
simply by asking so i think it's been
long enough
so let me explain why the definition is
there at the beginning of the video
each game symbolizes this word you can
also think of this word as a phrase
we won but at what cost and this is
arguably the single most defining phrase
of far cry
in each of the far cry games we win but
lose something in the process
jason brody was a simple american kid at
the beginning of the game
not knowing what to do in life but as we
progress we see him change and talking
about how he finally found what he wants
to do in his life and that it actually
has purpose
this all culminates at the final
decision each decision comes at a loss
of something
if jason allies with citra he has to
kill his friends to be a true rocky odd
warrior only to be killed immediately
after by citra herself as she says jason
was born a warrior and he will die a
warrior that's the final part of her
ritual being killed which would explain
why vos thinks citra
is crazy even if hypothetically he would
have lived that stab wound jason would
just live his life
killing pirates and being a bloodlusting
killer and once the pirates are gone
what's left the people of the island if
he chooses to leave the island then it
all was for nothing
citra is dead dennis and presumably the
rockyard don't like us anymore and
while yes he is alive and can return to
america with his friends what does he do
now
there is no purpose in his life he
doesn't want to go back to the jason
brody from the intro but he also doesn't
want it to come at the cost of his
friends so
he's stuck with no way out as we
explained previously aj's main goal and
only goal was to spread his mom's ashes
once again saying that he's thankful for
the golden path's help but that's not
why he's here
he was forced into this he probably
doesn't care for either sabal or amita
or their civil war he just wants to
respect his mother's dying wish and
leave but he has to join them and make
all these decisions for the leaders
which are both awful options
if zabal becomes leader of the golden
path he makes badra the tarun matara
which while not exactly proven it's
possible this role has some sexual
undertones to it and seeing as bhadra is
14 that's
definitely not the greatest look for
sabal especially since we can see him
killing members of the golden path who
allied with amida claiming that sins
like these can only be
washed away with blood with amita she
turns kirat into a drug state she orders
the rebels to go into people's houses
and take their kids from them so they
can work in the fields
each leader wants what they believe is
best for the country but in actuality
they're both awful leaders with wild
ideas and beliefs that are rooted in
dishonesty
even though aj most likely won't return
to kirot for quite some time and will
probably just go back to living in
america he still has to deal with the
ramifications of his journey
in the state he leaves his family home
country in to the people that died by
his hands whether they deserved it or
not
for the deputy some could argue that we
didn't even win
all the hard work of killing the seed
family and bringing back peace to the
county is all for nothing as the
collapse still happens
all the people we save the quests we did
the vehicles and weapons we all bought
it was a waste of time
joseph was right and he said in the
intro sometimes the best thing to do
is nothing the family needed to be
stopped they killed innocents who didn't
join them and tortured people in the
name of god but it's because
of these actions that caused us to deem
joseph as insane when he was correct the
entire time and lots of people died for
it although depending on your ending you
do get to live the collapse from what i
heard about far cry new dawn the deputy
ends up actually getting brainwashed by
the father since the only thing they
could do in the bunker was think the
deputy was constantly thinking about his
actions whether they were the right
choice or not he would eventually listen
to joseph's word and become part of his
new family
now he's the silent protector of new
eden possibly known as the judge which
is quite a sad turn of events for the
deputy in each of the games we win
we kill or stop the bad guys but each
ending came at the cost of something
relating to our protagonist whether it's
their friends
or their sanity this may be an
over-analysis of the character but the
deputy at the end of the game
is like us when we finish a far cry game
thinking for hours or
days even did we make the right choice
should i have chosen ceball over amida
in my playthrough should jason have
killed his friends
it's never been about choosing the good
or bad option in far cry it's always
been about choosing the lesser of two
evils as even though you may not know
what's coming like with far cry 5
it's a far cry game these aren't happy
fairy tales they're just games that make
us feel powerless yet invigorated in the
beginning
only to make us feel hollow by the end
of it
far cry is a series like no other able
to keep things consistent in mechanics
and plot placement but also able to
switch up the narrative of each
game making it just as good as the
previous entry whether it's giving the
player a laugh
questioning their own decisions or
leaving them feeling empty they all
serve their purpose of entertaining the
player
and getting them to think about their
narrative differently truly a
masterpiece of a series thank you all
for joining me today
let me know what you think about the
video in the comments down below this
took quite a bit of time to make but i
feel it was all worth it in the end
as always like the video if you enjoyed
subscribe if you're new so you can watch
more analysis videos on all your
favorite games just like this one
and with that take care and have a good
day
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you